esperienza che
io ho fatto da statistica per tutta la
mia vita
sono arrivata essere direttrice centrale
dell'istat ma in realtà io ero entrata
l'istat con un concorso di licenza media
inferiore
perché
non credevo nei titoli di studio non
credevo li consideravo pezzi di carta mi
sono laureata tardi a 31 anni pensavo
che la cultura è qualcosa che tu ti
costruisci
investendo in cultura appunto che non
c'era bisogno poi di avere un titolo di
studio
in realtà poi quando entrò all'istat mi
rendo conto che
c'erano molte cose che non andavano e in
particolare ho avuto la percezione
immediata che quella istituzione che
produceva un bene pubblico quindi
qualcosa di particolarmente rilevante
era assolutamente economico centrica
cioè in qualche modo
misurava
sostanzialmente fondamentalmente
fenomeni di natura
economica e quindi la centralità che
dava la misurazione statistica
era sui soggetti
produttivi
ora questa cosa era molto evidente
perché in realtà non era un problema
solo italiano è stato un problema per
decenni di tutti gli istituti nazionali
di statistica a livello internazionale
perché perché in realtà
si puntava non tanto la misurazione
dei bisogni
dei diversi soggetti sociali
ma alle priorità dell'economia
questa cosa significava delle cose
precise che i soggetti i soggetti
sociali erano visti più in un'ottica di
appendice a qualche altra cosa che
interessava e che era prioritaria per
esempio non è che interessavano tanto
gli anziani con i loro bisogni con le
loro necessità o la loro qualità della
vita
interessavano magari gli anziani e da un
punto di vista del carico pensionistico
per esempio che ovviamente è un elemento
importante da un punto di vista
statistico da un punto di vista
economico
così come sarebbe importante però doveva
essere importante anche avere una
chiarezza rispetto a quelli che erano i
bisogni degli anziani e anche i diritti
degli anziani
quanto effettivamente poi questi diritti
diventavano effettivamente fruibili e
questo senso la statistica diventa uno
strumento fondamentale
perché quanto più tu non riesce a
rendere
visibili gli indici visibili nelle
statistiche
tanto meno to riesce a rappresentare
quanto i loro diritti sono
effettivamente soddisfatti in questo
senso la statistica è fondamentale
soprattutto la statistica ufficiale è
fondamentale per la vita di una
democrazia
è quello che ti permette di verificare
realmente qual è la situazione
del paese nel in tutte le sue
sfaccettature
e qual è la situazione dei diversi
soggetti sociali che vivono nel paese
questa cosa succedeva per gli anziani
come succedeva per i bambini poteva
interessare il numero di alunni per
classe perché si aveva l'obiettivo di
razionalizzare per esempio il sistema
educativo nonché non fosse importante ma
non la qualità della vita dei bambini
poteva interessare
anche sulle donne magari si analizzavano
gli indicatori demografici il numero di
figli per donna
ma non era la donna al centro con i suoi
bisogni e le sue caratteristiche
c'era bisogno di un cambiamento di
paradigma
c'era bisogno di una vera e propria
rivoluzione copernicana
e lì io cioè ovviamente questa è una
razionalizzazione che è andata avanti no
poi col tempo inizialmente io cerca di
battermi come potevo su queste questioni
ma non aveva una laurea
ero avevo un ruolo all'interno
dell'istituto che non mi permetteva di
incidere come avrei potuto se avessi
avuto un ruolo decisionale di tipo
diverso e quindi la capi che mi dovevo
lavorare
e quindi ho investito in questa cosa
mentre lavoravo e naturalmente mi sono
resa conto che era molto importante è
molto importante perché acquisire
competenze in più e poi delle vedove
giocare te le potevi giocare molto
meglio e quindi
mi laureo di vento ricercatrice vinco
tutti con forse dovevo vincere in dieci
anni concorsi nazionali
poi dopo tre anni di vento direttrice
centrale dell'istat che questo percorso
che s'avvia in realtà comincia a
esserci serve scienza proprio rispetto a
queste tematiche cominciò a polle e
questo va di pari passo con un processo
di innovazione che si attiva che si
attiva dentro l'istat e quindi questa
cambiamento diciamo così di paradigma
questa rivoluzione copernicana comincia
a
prendere forma e prendere forma
significa tante cose significa che si
sviluppano le statistiche di genere e
quindi sia una immediata come dire
valutazione e misurazione di una cosa
che banale la misura del lavoro non
retribuito ma che non esisteva cioè non
si sapeva quanto era tutti sapevano che
le donne in italia sono sovraccariche di
lavoro retribuito ma non si sapeva
quanto quant'erano sfiore mentre si
sapeva quante ore di lavoro no venivano
svolte perché le ore di lavoro sono nel
pil quindi erano funzionali alla
misurazione di un dato cruciale per
l'economia italiana e quindi si comincia
con quello si arriva fino a misurare la
violenza contro le donne è mica una cosa
facile perché anche le misure c'erano
c'era la misura delle rinunce
c'era la misura dei femminicidi
purtroppo ma non c'erano misure del
sommerso della violenza è difficile
misurarlo è stato difficilissimo anche
se è stata una delle cose più
affascinanti dal punto di vista seppur
drammatica dal punto di vista della
misurazione ci abbiamo messo 5 anni per
trovare la metodologia
per stimare il numero di donne che
avevano subito violenza
perché perché lì problema è che la
statistica ti permette tu hai un metodo
scientifico che applichi ai delle
tecniche che puoi
utilizzare queste combinate con la tua
creatività con la tua competenza ti
permettono di arrivare per
approssimazioni successive ai risultati
ma noi abbiamo dovuto testare
questionari e indagini diverse
ma saremo arrivati a una ventina di test
differenti
coinvolgendo donne che avevano subito
violenza coinvolgendo i centri
antiviolenza cioè è stato un lavoro
difficilissimo
molto complesso perché ogni fenomeno ha
bisogno di essere misurato tenendo conto
delle caratteristiche e complessità e
specificità di quel fenomeno e delle
persone che sono state che sono
coinvolte diciamo che sono i soggetti
con cui deve interloquire per sapere e
come si fa a chiedere una donna ha
subito violenza dal proprio partner
questa è una cosa è stata una cosa
complessa primo non si poteva chiedere
se aveva subito violenza perché molte
donne non ti rispondevano che era
violenza la violenza portata avanti dal
proprio partner perché magari la
rimuovevano no la consideravano tale
speravano per fosse un fatto un fatto
occasionale
speravano che fosse un momento di
nervosismo
purtroppo questa è una cosa che c'è che
c'è ancora e che è molto diffusa e
allora primo elemento eliminare il
vocabolo violenza descrivere gli atti
senza dargli un valore secondo aspetto
non bastava perché i partner non
uscivano veniva fuori l'amico il
conoscente non veniva fuori il partner e
allora come fare
eppure i centri antiviolenza noi avevamo
questo riscontro i centri antiviolenza
dicevano che tutte quelle che arrivavano
nei centri nella stragrande maggioranza
erano violenze da parte di partner e
allora cambiavi e alla fine abbiamo
capito noi non chiedevamo direttamente
partner per non irritare la donna per
metterla in una condizione più così più
a suo agio in realtà era l'inverso cioè
le donne avevano bisogno comunque che tu
glielo chiedessi in qualche modo perché
se tu stessi legittimando il fatto che
era possibile
che una donna potesse subire anche degli
atti di questo tipo da un partner e
questo inizialmente non pensavamo che
fosse corretto in realtà attraverso
questo meccanismo
siamo riusciti invece a farle emergere
quindi per approssimazioni successive
destando metodi diversi per raggiungere
l'obiettivo
alla fine ci siamo riusciti certo uno
può sempre dire ma siamo sicuri che
quello è il risultato
preciso ovviamente no esiste un
intervallo no di validità
diciamo di quel risultato
certo è che siccome quella informazione
essendo statistica ufficiale è bene
pubblico
tu devi investire al massimo per
avvicinarti più possibile al valore vero
e questo è un esempio di come
effettivamente
la statistica ti permette di mettere al
centro un problema prima non si parlava
di violenza sulle donne quanto si parla
ora era qualcosa che era limitato alle
quattro mura e quindi ci si riferiva
questo fenomeno molto ma molto raramente
adesso come vediamo a quasi tutti i
telegiornali e no ci si arriva a parlare
di questo ma ci si arriva anche perché
quello è stato un punto di passaggio di
rottura fondamentale perché e questo è
l'importanza di queste statistiche per
la democrazia
tu hai di fronte una realtà una realtà
che è oggettiva con cui devi fare con e
quindi il diritto di una donna di essere
libera dalla violenza così come il
diritto di una persona lgbt come è
successo dopo con le indagini che sono
state fatte sulla misurazione
dell'omofobia
oppure ancora dopo con l'indagine che
sono state fatte sugli homeless e come è
stato possibile stato possibile perché
il fattore umano entrato profondamente
tutte queste indagini sono state fatte
con un forte
approccio di condivisione primo dentro
l'istat si è creato un gruppo molto
ampio di donne e uomini non solo
competenti ma appassionata che hanno
messo competenza passione e motivazione
nel raggiungere questo obiettivo di dare
visibilità agli invisibili e di creare
questo cambiamento di paradigma
secondo un fattore umano che si è
concretizzato anche in una forte
condivisione con la società civile
perché tu se vuoi misurare come vivono
gli homeless e vuoi stimare quanti sono
gli homeless è un'altra delle cose molto
complicate perché tu devi andare a
contare in giro per tutto il paese
quanti sono e dove sono
bene tu lo puoi fare solo coinvolgendo
proprio quelle organizzazioni che sui
territori con gli homeless hanno un
rapporto perché altrimenti forse può
arrivare a contarli bene anche detto ma
certo non riesci ad avere un dialogo con
loro per capire che cosa gli è successo
per cui tu riesci a capire quale dalle
storie di ciascuno dalle storie riesce a
capire effettivamente quali sono i
percorsi per esempio
separazione perdita del lavoro sono i
due punti cruciali per cui si cade nella
situazione si arriva nella situazione di
homeless e questo però ci arrivi nel
momento in cui hai grande supporto non
lo puoi fare da solo come istituto di
statistica è bisogno di creare
condivisione con la società civile che
ti aiuta nel condividere
questi obiettivi e questo è valso pure
quando abbiamo fatto l'indagine che ne
so su omofobia
perché anche lì
noi sappiamo che c'è un problema anche a
dichiararsi moltissimi casi e lino
l'abbiamo detto esplicito l'omofobia è
una misurazione che puoi fare
intervistando tutti ma quando poi chiede
alla persona se omosessuale si è trans e
così via
non tutti sono disposti ad aprirsi e è
molto più difficile ancora di più della
violenza sulle donne
tant'è che alla fine lo abbiamo stimato
un milione però dichiarando che quel
milione che avevamo stimato era comunque
un valore basso allora perché dico tutto
questo dico tutto questo è perché
c'entra il fattore umano
il fattore umano
c'entra perché primo obiettivo è stato
un grande obiettivo di una netta
mettere al centro della misurazione alle
statistiche ufficiali i soggetti
l'individuo con le loro caratteristiche
i loro bisogni e i loro diritti